you guys have a lot of good famous
friends if you had a murder normally
famous friends only famous friends if
you had a murder mystery dinner who
would you invite and who do you think
would do the murdering well the truth is
whenever for real I say hey Jane can I
bring my friend over for dinner shoes
who would we have so we may have any
dinner would be a possible murderer now
you said who would who would do the
killing who would be the people that
would come in who would do the killing
Oh Conan O'Brien would be an amazing
murderer really yeah that's true
that's good yeah you want it to be no
Lisa Lisa Kudrow would be the best she'd
actually be the best and I think I'd
still be on her side even during the
murder I guess this person deserves at
least is so nice she's so good that they
deserve to get killed said you guys lot
of stunts in this movie what did you do
that with yours would you do that was it
yours
oh don't tell anybody one right that was
on you and that was supposed to be you
and then all of us in the stuntwoman
community kiss at the end up I didn't
make out with the stunt lady no yes she
goes let me just do one with him so it
looks kind of real
you did good let's see what your stunts
were you you [ __ ] shot the gun we fell
through a window yeah you went cold out
of a dry a driveway and then there is
cleaner the drag and then there was a
couple no and that was pretty much it
but those Italian stunt men are guys
they're fearless did you see the little
tiny road oh yeah thank God you stunt
lady in for the when you're doing an
haircutting scene you like I'm afraid oh
my god and so we had to fly out stuff
your lunch
what was it like I mean was it like this
the whole time the two of you just back
and forth the craziness going on all day
I followed Jen she's funny hi I'm when
she's being funny I'm funny when she's
being serious I go everyone listen up
Jennifer's got something to say and then
she gets it done leads us in the right
direction elite er of this movie you
were very where can we work I don't know
I like so much I like you
we had fun but miss that's basically we
that's what we do
there really is the 30th anniversary of
you meeting I do remember when I didn't
meet you I remember thinking you were
funny and very instant yeah
oh man like how did we had all these
certain we just knew a lot of the same
thing yeah but we always supposed to
went in and had a little good hangs and
then we got to finally make a movie
together they just go yeah I can't I
gave at four or five callbacks and then
on the fifth when I was like listen we
want to do this with you but no no I
just I think she's great and couldn't
wait to do another one with her and she
apparently she could wait so I had the
wig night forever
yeah why did he take so long just
finding the right script well I kept
saying what about this she'd be like
this shouldn't it be good I'd be like no
do it let's just do one better no it was
it was it was just finding the right and
we had actually found this a couple
years ago mm-hmm and then it was just
about finding the right time and the
right bird and getting it to the place
that was our minds you know and
shootable
you rocked a lot of basketball shorts
that could go to the basketball she was
still is my go-to today though I got
pants on you want sweats right no real
way to hip-hop these are real pants I
got pockets their pockets here yeah I
could have gone shorts I didn't I knew I
asked I would hate it do you have a
certain appear is there a certain pair
that he would wear a lot or is it did he
mix it up shove that on your
I have I literally I have two drawers I
know the top drawer I go through them
all and I have about I swear to God
about maybe 25 30 pairs of shorts and
then so I go what fits me more if I've
been eating a lot oh my god so it
depends on food intake all about the
chair bottom drawers just a little bit
double XE I'm like let's go double a see
you ever gone double XE in a while I'm
gonna have in the middle of the next
good you just did morning show with
Reese how's that how was that it was a
morning show anchor but I love doing
what you do yeah yes you want to see
it's really it was really fun and it's
gonna be hopefully really enjoyed by
many people it was very interesting to
do it and then I actually learn what I
learned about everything that actually
goes on behind them and what shot you
what shot you
oh I can't even say good stuff though
good stuff did you just by the way you
just count me out did you wrap I think
she just wrapped me I think she was like
yeah two one get him out yeah
[Music]